so this dialogue is what often called on
friendship
why because what's the main thing these
guys are talking about friendship and
you notice there's a lot of friends in
this that are being referred to it
you've got the two young guys who tell
Socrates hey come on over here we want
to talk with you a while
at the very beginning anyone remember
their names they're kind of hard to
pronounce he comes a little bit later
what's that
there's Hipple Thal ace and that was
then one takes a little getting used to
your tongue you know stumbles over it
and then there's consists that's a Morse
right so we're probably not going to
talk too much about yeah let me make
sure I've actually pronouncing here
right consider this because it's this CT
sound yeah the Greeks had a lot of funny
names I was asking my wife do you the
other night as I was going through this
you know just imagine if we had a kid
and we named him things like men in
excess you know how that go she was not
very impressed now they they want to
talk to Socrates and these are guys
Socrates is an older guy he's got a
reputation of going around and talking
with just about anybody about anything
and he's always asking people questions
or you probably encountered what your
teacher called the Socratic method some
type of high school or middle school
when the teacher would just ask you well
why do you think that and can you give
me a reason for that and that is kind of
like the Socratic method there's a bit
more to it than that you actually have
to have some ideas at least to start but
the main the main thing that Socrates
does is tries to figure out whether
people actually are able to provide
reasons or accounts or
explanations for the things that they
seem to think that they know about now
you know friendship love these are
things that we often do think we know
about right we've experienced them we
have friends who experience them we're
all here as a product of some you know
pair of you know getting together and
hopefully actually liking each other and
being attracted to each other and you
know that's how we all got here so
presumably we know something about this
stuff but what Socrates is going to show
us and what Plato shows us is if we if
we start probing and we start pushing
turns out some of this is more puzzling
than than at first glance and one of the
guys HIPAA Thal ace is already stuck in
some some puzzles and problems himself
because he's in love and you know it's
it's on friendship but it actually
begins with somebody who's in love so
there's already kind of a bi valence of
shifting back and forth there that you
want to be attentive to and careful
about a little bit later I met a nexus
and Lissa's we gotta the dialogue is
named after they end up in conversation
as well and these are younger guys so
imagine people HIPAA thoughts and
sickness are probably about your age
right now and imagine that meta Nexus
and and listless are like you know
middle school or junior high to high
school kids so there's there's there's
an age difference there and they're
really good friends and now everybody
here in this this story is from what we
would tend to call an upper class family
Socrates is as well but he's he's more
or less you know wasting his his
inheritance by not working an awful lot
and just you know living the life of a
citizen doing her out
so he's you know slidin down but these
other people are from fairly well-to-do
families we notice that men in excess
and list
have this whole bunch of attendants and
tutors that are charged with taking care
of them that come in drunk at the very
end and we'll talk about that in a
minute
where is the dialogue actually taking
place
does anyone remember these are probably
words that didn't strike you that much
you're like some Greek place no idea
what this word Palestra means yeah yeah
it's it's an outdoor venue you might say
the way most things tend to be back then
it's at a Palestra Socrates says I was
going from the Academy to the Lyceum and
I mentioned this before both of those at
that time were not schools of philosophy
they were actually gymnasiums the Greeks
were really into working out and being
healthy and you don't think about what
other people what people do in gyms do
they just work out some gyms are like
that you know I knew guys actually when
I used to go to the Y when I was in high
school
I knew guys who would do the real
workout at the Y and then they'd go -
where was it valleys or Vic Tanny or
something like that to try to you know
pick up members of the opposite sex they
weren't really there and workout they
were there to do other things socialize
right yeah the Greeks did that too they
would have conversations they would hang
out with each other so there's you know
a friendship going to the gym was part
of that the Palestra where they are
that's the kind of place that was used
for training for and having wrestling
and boxing matches the Greeks were
pretty into that sort of stuff as well
boxing mental something a little bit
different back then it was a little bit
more violent so that you can imagine
that and the current sport that we have
it's not to say that everybody did this
but you know they saw some value to that
so already there's kind of hints about
what's going on there this is this is a
place where they're going to be rash
the things and Plato is doing something
pretty typical of Plato you're gonna see
this in the symposium you know in a
symposium originally is it's like a
party isn't it yeah let's get together
and drink and you're gonna notice I'm
talking about drinking at the start and
the only reason why they don't drink
hard that night at the symposium because
they drink so hard the night before that
even though it's the late afternoon
they're still hungover some of that from
the night before now Plato will take
things like that ordinary earthly
experiences and he'll what we call
sublimate them sort of transform them
into occasions where people talked about
things where they had important
conversations where they thought about
things trying to work them out this
one's going to be unsuccessful they're
not going to attain the definition of
friendship that they're looking for but
you should ask yourself is it really
unsuccessful do they accomplish anything
along the way if you read between the
lines characters we talked about a
little bit already there's we don't know
that much about these people
historically we don't really need to we
don't need to worry about whether this
actually happened or not it's kind of a
teaching story they're engaged in
conversation and think about this how
should you after having read it several
times how should you approach these
conversations is Socrates just talking
to these dead guys back in ancient
Athens and a Palestra during the Hermia
you know some festival that we've never
heard of but apparently people like to
drink during that festival as well what
they're doing most festivals where is he
busy talking to anybody else think about
why Plato wrote this down when we write
down things
yeah now you're getting somebody else's
ideas so that it's not like he's sorting
through your ideas it makes sense I mean
Plato wouldn't have known you we died
millennia ago but you're on the right
track
yeah yeah there's something to that too
I mean Plato is putting across a point
of view you have to dig it a little bit
in order to to get it you have to pay
attention where the dialogue twists and
turns sort of like a movie that you have
to watch really carefully in order to
figure out what what actually happened
in this movie do you think you know at
first of them you watch it the second
time you're like oh yeah that's what it
was about Plato's dialogues are like
that they are designed to be tools to
make you think here's one basic
assumption that Plato has whoever I'm
writing to is not going to be so
radically different from where I'm
writing and the time that I'm writing in
that this won't make any sense to them
at all imagine for example we've got
these words like love and friendship up
here imagine if we didn't mean anything
whatsoever by that you know listen Amy
you know let's let's assume that we're
not doing any science fictiony kind of
thing you know robots that can law or
feel affection or anything like that
imagine if he wrote this - and it was
sent to a bunch of beings like like
robots that didn't have any emotions a
lot of these words wouldn't make sense a
lot of what these people are talking
about wouldn't make sense but you have
these emotions doing it and you've seen
other people have done yeah now here's
the thing to think about our things so
fundamentally different in Plato's time
when it comes to these basic drives and
experiences from our own are there they
so radically different than this that
this wouldn't be a
an effective teaching device what is he
dealing with things that are kind of
constants of human nature things that
we're gonna have to live through and
figure out every every new generation
because we do share something in common
well I mean that's that's an open
question we don't think answer that
right now thinking about that as we play
through this so one thing that he's
providing you with here and you might
not have caught this on the first or
second reading but I created this
handout to defend help you with is we're
getting to think not just about take
questions what is long right we're
getting models or conceptions of what
love or friendship really are yeah
Socrates tends to jump from one of these
to the next fairly quickly and one of
the problems with this dialogue one of
the reasons why it ends up into what we
call a Korea is you know he's dealing
with with a bunch of kids who have not
thought a lot about this and don't have
a lot of training in carrying out this
kind of analysis so they're not they're
not asking him the right questions at
the right point they're not actually
stopping him and saying whoa wait a
second Socrates you just said this but I
think we could actually make make some
sort of you know counter example or
exception here or maybe we need to make
a distinction there they don't have
those tools those are those basic tools
of philosophy that we're trying to
acquire and then you know you acquire
them by it's by exercising them by
knowing that you need to do them instead
they jump from model to model to model
and they don't really see although maybe
Socrates does that they're shifting the
grounds of the debate we're going to
look at these different models in part
because maybe we do need to separate
them out and some of them pose really
interesting questions that you probably
have asked yourself at one point or
another and it'd be nice to read those
questions into this dialogue
these are some of the questions that
sort of give me a sling who were
actually friends and you've probably had
to ask yourself this in the singular
about one person or another in your life
is this person really my friend or are
they no longer my friend or are they
really my enemy you know somebody who
may treated you badly who you call the
friend you might have actually you know
been a moment of remorse asked yourself
second thing have I been a good friend
to so itself or have I been a lousy
friend is there one single form of
friendship is there one overarching
definition that we can bring it all
under or do we have to distinguish
different kinds of friendship
what is the cause or the reason why are
we actually friends or if you think
about love why you know why do we feel
the way that we do towards other people
why do they feel the way that they do
towards us and just as interesting is
that how do these work you know when
somebody is involved you can you can
figure it out right when you're when one
of your friends falls in love with
somebody how do they start to act that's
a little bit different than how they
probably normally act unless there's
somebody who's in love all the time yeah
romantic somebody who loves to be in
love okay they get happy yeah how how
does this show goofy smile that tell me
somethings up ya know what are you
smiling about it's not a good day like
it's rainy you know back to school again
humid in here what are you so happy
about
think about that yeah
yeah in our age where we have all these
ways of communicating with each other
like text messages phones that we can
actually carry around you know something
that didn't exist two generations ago
you really know that that something's
going on but they don't respond to
Facebook things they're busy with other
things or you know you can actually
watch on Facebook they're constantly
engaged in the interaction with this one
person right how do they talk about that
first
if they're actually ruling the land
what's up yeah there are people who are
in love don't usually say I hate the
guts out of this person she's so
terrible you know they do there's
something really conflicted talking
about me right
usually they you know when she walks you
know like the ground turns of the
flowers are you know people start
getting very poetic I think she's the
one
you know heard of those cans well I was
doing that in this story that's getting
treated very early on yeah yeah holidays
in LA and if we wanted to distinguish
different kinds of love the word that we
would often use for this is he is
infatuated
with this you know for a lot of us
because our sensibilities are a little
bit differently informed than the
ancient Greeks that might be a little
jarring wait what he's in love with one
of his classmates but some other young
guy oh yeah
he's attracted to him there's certain
qualities about him but you notice he
does the same thing that people do in
cultures throughout time once he becomes
infatuated with them he's driving his
actual friends nuts by talking about him
constantly and when he talks about him
he doesn't just you know say yeah I was
walking down the street and I met hippo
Ollis he's got to like write poetry and
the poetry is this is this bombastic
stuff where you know tracing his
ancestry all the way back to being
friends with Hercules you know it's
really over-the-top kind of stuff but
you know thinking through your
experience of your friends and I'm not
gonna ask you about you know thinking
things that you've done when you've been
involved in think about some of the
goofy things your friends have done and
said let that fit the model do they
sometimes feel embarrassed about hefty
boards I can't believe I they said those
things it spent so much money on flowers
yeah printed out this this beautiful you
know view people do a lot of crazy
things for love because they are
infatuated with the object of their
desire it's kind of blinding isn't it
maybe Lysias is not as impressive as
Hipple thoughtless is made about to be
he's a good guy but he's not you know
he's not love incarnate or something
like that
Socrates points out a problem with this
to a lot of what's going to go on in
this dialogue is Socrates pointing out
what we might call paradoxes or of our
contradictions and when somebody is
infatuated let's let's put them over
here right you've got the person that
they're infatuated with how does that
person
often act what are the different ranges
of possibilities sometimes we find out
that somebody likes us and then we're
more willing to look at them in a
positive light and we may not have even
realized that we actually like them to
this was like a spark over here it's a
spark over here that's nice when that
happens what what more often tends to be
the case yeah yeah you know you're
really writing too many poems to me I
gotta take three a day you know it
becomes oppressive so that's a problem
now that's usually fairly honest people
who will say yeah I just don't I don't
want that sort of thing with you what
some other people do less less we call
it not necessarily honest but yeah
people who are willing to take advantage
of
yeah that's a real danger when you
become infatuated and when you do become
infatuated you're probably not gonna
listen to your friends saying yes stay
away from hammer stay away from bad
track record there a user because you're
not going to see that right the
infatuation blinds you to it the other
thing is Socrates talks about he likens
the logger to a band hunter the hunter
who scares away his prey and then the
process of pursuit and one of the
possibilities with this is that the
person who's being praised by by the
Oratory you know who's liking the fact
that this other person is is buying them
things saying nice things about them
they start to get a swelled head
they start to get an inflated ego as we
say alright I start to think very highly
of themselves particularly if the person
is pursuing them is you know rich or
prestigious or very good-looking they
tend to start to think that that's you
know who they really are who they are in
the eyes of the lover is who they who
they truly are and Socrates says that's
all fine if you actually get the object
of your desire because if you if you
talk them up really high and you get
them then you're you're a big success
and everyone looks at you and says wow
you know she got the guy or he got the
girl
more likely though you're actually gonna
give them reasons for not spending any
time with you if there is great as you
make the hook to begin if they start
thinking that way what I'm thinking what
want to spend time with you you're just
some infatuated person and they could
pick from all sorts of people who
perhaps they're infatuated so this is an
interesting model love it's got some
problems to it it tends to blind us
right this is where they begin
what do they what do they switch to them
well they walk into the Palestra further
and now you've got this funny scene
where him pathologies is trying out you
know hang back so them so his beloved
can't see him but he can see him there's
all sorts we'll get on almost
Hitchcockian themes there and off any of
you rent on that sort of film stuff and
Socrates starts asking the younger guys
about their about their life together
but first he first my Nexus takes off
he's going to do some sacrifices stuff
so imagine you know in our days he's got
to go to church for a little while right
come back hang out with his he's gonna
hang out with his family and then come
back so I could you just talk with
lysias and he's asking him about about
what about a different kind of love
this is you know the law of save parents
for children but you know this could be
for any sort of position of
responsibility so you know the the nurse
is an award for for patients who are
just not going to improve maybe that
could be similar or patients that are
going to the teacher-student
relationship in certain cases you know
if you develop a mentor that could be
like that no notice what Socrates starts
out you starts out saying your mom and
dad love you
right and Lisi says yeah hey they love
me and what does he start to ask these
probing questions about that yeah and
you know the freedom really has to do
with what they don't use this word in in
this dialogue but what we would call
having fun enjoyment you know what a
kids like to do mess around with stuff
you know we don't still like to mess
around with stuff don't wait yeah you
guys are all very well behaved you've
learned to control impulses and urges to
just monkey around of things but that's
part of you know that's where human
beings are kind of close to the monkeys
yeah we do like we are curious my cats -
cats are terrible for that sort of thing
we like to to mess around with with
things to figure out how they work to
have a try ourselves right and his
parents don't let him do that
they are so repressive they don't let
him do anything this start to sound like
you know adolescence circa 2010 it's
really the same sort of thing isn't it
now why don't his parents let him say
drive the chariot
I think that's taking the car up
or even you know whip the Buell - no
they let the mule it's here do that his
mom doesn't let him mess around at the
spinning wheel the spinning wheels by
the way none of you know this but you
can really get hurt at them there that
that thing spinning fast you ever like
on a bike had the tire spinning and you
stick your finger in this folks you only
do that once
same thing with spinning wheels why
don't they let him do all these things
yeah yeah the dangerous and the parents
actually do the care further their kid
and sometimes it means saying no right
now you get the impression from the way
that Socrates is to tell you what they
say no to everything well it is the
slaves job but the slave is also the one
who knows what he's doing yeah and mules
are dangerous too you know it's kind of
funny we you know we live lives that are
very very insulated we're extremely it's
not just security but safety conscious
in this society most societies in the
world there's so many ways that you
could injure yourself or die that you
have to kind of work at here in the
United States to get to there's a class
dimension there do you think the mule
appears son or daughter has the same
degree of surveillance where they're not
allowed to do this they're not allowed
to do this because we've got people to
take care of that for us probably not
because they can't afford that we by the
way in our society we don't do that
through slaves or servants for the most
part we do that through through
technology and you know if I if I want
it's send a message to somebody I got
Syria Syria doesn't understand me very
well she gets my voice wrong harmless
things on earth very unimpressed with my
Siri so I was typing it this is acting
like a servant or me its insulating me
from the world we do that with
technology but in ancient society they
had servants to do that and you're right
you know
it was a large part of man who could
afford it but there are some things that
good parents just in general are not
gonna let their kids do even though the
kids might want to do them let's think
it's a really basic don't drink any
poison you know that stuff that's under
the cupboards don't don't drink that
because that'll screw you up you know
maybe kill you and we don't want that
because we actually care about you don't
go play in the construction site we're
kids that's what we want to play all the
time and that's what the coolest stuff
was right but it's not a good idea
you can get hurt pretty easily and then
when you get hurt all the other kids
tend to you know scatter because it's in
trouble so you might be there for a
while what else what else don't we like
kids do don't go run across the street
and parents will do what they'll yell at
the kids sometimes spank them take
privileges away so it doesn't really
sound like the parents love them do that
maybe they did them it wasn't often what
we call tough love mm-hmm now Socrates
is kind of he sounds almost like you
know a little devil whispering and
Melissa's here doesn't he and ruining is
his adolescent experience for him but
then he shifts and here we get to a
third sort of model of thousands at the
moment this one's a bit more
philosophical here they started asking
why do people like other people why do
they why do they want to be friends with
them why do they let them
and it brings up things like you know
the Great King cooking the Great King as
the king of Persia does the Empire you
know across the the pond from Greece
that they fought a war with in Socrates
over a long time when are we friends
with people when do we respect them you
might say he doesn't use the word
respect in here but when do we say I'm
going to go with what you had to say
when they when they know what they're
doing and the lover loves the person
who's loved because the person who's
loved he has some sort of knowledge or
skill or competency and what does this
let them do this lets them provide
something good you know you got a friend
who knows how to mix drinks really well
that's a skill call that bartending all
right
the mortar bartending then is mixing
drinks to comedy racial dynamics and
knowing when to cut somebody off for
part of it somebody who knows how to fix
your your your sink when it's broken
they're a nice friend to him right
make Reds the plumbers because you'll
need plumbers sooner or later some
friends who might be friends with
because they help you out in class right
they get you through the the calculus
class that you're struggling or the
history class or some
because they really like that stuff
here's another tip if you know how to
cook you will have friends if you know
how to cook well provided you're not -
you know snooty about it you know
insistently taste everything the way
that you want to be done those people
off the road at the culinary are gaining
themselves not only a marketable skill
but one that's great for social
intercourse so those are goods and why
does the lover care about them the lover
has some sort of need that good
satisfies the need and this is what we
call on the part of the person up here
usefulness they are a useful person you
know I mean if you want to know a lot
about Plato's dialogues or you know
Aristotle's works you can go to
Wikipedia and you can you know download
videos or you can come to somebody like
me and hang out for awhile and sooner or
later you'll find out something about
Plato yeah so does that reflected if two
people that are in love oh okay that's a
very good question she doesn't talk
about it a dabble and this is one of
those of those cases where we can push
the text further and say yeah what about
this are the two people in love both in
this case where they're they're
satisfying each other's needs in some
way and that's why the relationship
exists he will touch on stuff like that
later and it could be in terms of being
in love like romantic lungs that we
usually think about or a companionship
you know or it could be friendship you
know we're friends with each other
because I take so-and-so to the concerts
that he likes going to and he's got a
nice house on the lake that he invites
me to and that's the base of basis of
our friendship all right that could that
could be the way that it works now this
is kind of a when you first hear about
this this sounds like a kind of cynical
view on friendship
and in love relations doesn't it but you
know think back to your own experience
my wife was putting me at pointing this
out to me in the car on the way down yet
stage in your life that you're currently
yeah a good many of the friendships as
you would call them which you're
probably not gonna call friendships
don't align then you haven't been
products of circumstance you were thrown
together on the same team in the same
class you live down the same block right
you may not actually have that much in
common with those people and now you're
here in college and some of your friends
from high school went to different
colleges and the question is are you
going to stay friends with them because
if it's just a matter of physical
proximity and being you know engaged in
the same activities that's not going to
maintain the friendship because there's
somewhere else so what would maintain
the friendship you might have actually
have thought about this and you probably
should be on the lookout for friends of
yours who are thinking this way
well is this person still useful to me
am I still gonna get it get anything
that I need out of them if so keep them
in your contact lists make sure to email
them or send a Facebook message once
every couple weeks or so so you're still
on the radar as we say alright still in
their thoughts and affections is this
all there is to Friendship this is the
case for some friendships isn't it this
is the case even for some people who
love each other they love the other
person because they're getting something
out of the other person that they need
it could be sex it could be validation
it could be security it could be who
know and when that when that good goes
away when that person can no longer
supply that then the basis for the
friendship disappears doesn't it people
say we've grown apart oftentimes that
means I realized you're no longer useful
to me and I am probably not not useful
to you if that's what the friendship was
based on so this is something we want to
think a lot about is this the whole
you know the whole account Socrates
seems to be saying it is doesn't he he
makes reference to this a couple more
times over the course of the dialogue
let's look at one other camp friendship
one that's understanding that some of
these could be could be people in types
of people when somebody says I love cats
what do they mean do they mean I have
developed deep and abiding friendships
with with you know my feline friends do
they mean you know I have this feeling
of romantic love as I would for a
potential mate for my cat who's there
are some people who have you know
fetishes like that but I don't think we
want to take them as the norm per foot
you want to discuss as that when most
people say I love cats
what are they not that what we just
described yeah okay so two important
things there being with them spending
time with them enjoying them presumably
they like some of the things that cats
bless you some of these cats do like you
know they find purring cute or they you
know they like their little paws or they
you know they play with the you know the
string and they give the can't bat sit
around and they get into that right and
I mean you know a lot of people find
cancer IQs whether the law all cats meme
is like constantly generating your stuff
and if you put up you know a kitten
video kittens doing anything on YouTube
feels like a million hits because people
like watching fuzzy little cats doing
things but you talk about the idea you
know people who are really really cat
people
they don't just want to hang out with
cats
they'll send you a cat themed greeting
card everything's got to be about cats
the sweater with a cat on it you know
they'll go to cap shows or watch them on
TV and we can think about this as a lot
of other things if you're really really
really into collecting something you
probably know what the convention for it
is right yeah and when that comes to
town you're off that whole week because
you're busy at that convention hanging
out with the other people who share your
interest your passion your did it your
desire and Socrates brings up a couple
animal examples he talks about people
being you know crazy about dogs you know
some people are really into dogs for
hunting you know they train them for
that then from a long association you
know we've got a semi-retired hunting
dog at my uncle's place and my uncle and
my cousin will take her out every so
often and she is just you know she's a
black lamb and they were dead that's
what they were bred to do that's that's
their nature that's their function and
she is never more happy than when even
though she's arthritic and has a hard
time with you know the cold when she's
out there hunting ducks with them that
is like heaven for her and they really
enjoy it and there's something you know
there's something find about that other
people are into Socceroos excellent
horses or roosters they live presumably
the Greeks were in a [ __ ] fighting you
know
and man I don't know what else they they
were interested in roosters for maybe
timepieces so some people are the
animals that way what are other things
that people get really excited about
passion for yeah all right yeah now he
doesn't talk about that and I guess
maybe the Athenians were not as into the
chariots but you know but like the 18th
century
did you read literature you will find
people who are obsessed with carriages
this this car fascination has been going
on for a very long time before there
were cars yeah yeah accessories you know
we have a whole industry geared towards
just talking about that stuff not even
producing just talking about you know
fashion magazines yeah yeah people get
really into and it's usually not music
per se it'll be like this kind of music
or this band yeah oh yeah that would uh
again he doesn't talk about that the
ancient Greeks didn't have teams per se
like that it was more individual
athletes at games by Roman times people
would actually get so worked up it was
the chariot races they had the Blues the
Greens of lights and somebody else and I
mean these fans would actually kill each
other literally they would stab each
other you're you're a green they felt so
strongly about it so I mean that told
you the infection is there
Socrates talks about people also being
passionately engaged with things like
prestige or honor they they desire that
so much people who want other people to
look at them as being great people that
is a motivation one of the guys who
you're actually getting to read about in
the symposium later on Alcibiades he's
motivated by that that's that's just his
fundamental
Socrates says that he is a lover of
friends where other people want to have
as many dogs as possible or you know
putting it into her own time you know
the first edition of this or that he
wants to have quality friends that's
what makes his life really complete he
has a passionate desire about this he
doesn't go on and talk much more about
this this is probably something that
we'll explore more when we get to other
other texts since he just kind of drops
it but it's worth thinking about is this
is this rational is this just something
that is inflicted on us is it something
that we can you know say hey this makes
sense up to this limit can this be the
basis for friendships to form if you and
I like the same sports teams
maybe we hang out and now we suddenly
have the basis because we have a shared
common thing that we're obsessed with
you know this could also be problems
yeah yeah you know here sure could be a
way in which you become rivals I'm the
bigger Packer fan no I'm the I'm the
real Packer fan hitting each other until
we find a Bears fan to pick on
yeah sports sports stuff is very
irrational I love it too it's fun to
watch
not just the team's themselves but the
fans crazy they some things are let's
talk about another Cathy talks about I
just mention this friendship may be
friendship involves what we would call
mutual affection and this isn't
something that would apply to all types
of love you know think about if you love
dogs I know people think that their dogs
love them but does the dog love you in
the same way that you love the dog
probably not because the dog the dog is
capable of affection and sometimes very
deep and lasting affections there are
cases where you know I want or dies the
dog keeps coming to the same place year
after year after year the Japanese are
actually elected in a shrine to a puppy
that did that for like a decade after
its owner died because it showed loyalty
you might you might say yeah my dog and
I are friends or my cat and I are
friends probably not with your snake or
your tarantulas
affections but you can't do with them
what you can do in the human trap you
can't have the same sort of fullness
richness what Socrates calls loving and
return a concept that's going to be very
important for other later discussions of
friendship and even of marriage you know
whatever that weird thing is is a
friendship as a gist sexual desire isn't
you know some sort of contractual
arrangement that we could call marriage
through the ages in the Middle Ages this
was something that was considered really
important for her for marriage Socrates
doesn't really go into that that much
what he's pointing out to us at least is
that look when it comes to say being in
love with an idea the idea doesn't love
you back
when it comes to lobbying your sports
team you may feel like they love you
because they they put you on the
jumbotron or something that they don't
love you back okay even if they give you
season tickets because you're such a
great fan they don't love you in the
same way that you do them that's not
that's not the basis for friendship with
you know mutual affection what about
with kids what we just talked about that
if you're the parent you have to say no
an awful lot yeah and you also have to
keep yourself from you know losing your
temper and you know there's some
comedian to talk about this you know
attendance we don't want to choke your
kid you know because the crazy stuff
they get into you can't do that right
and so because you love them you keep
that sort of stuff on it controlling you
you know you you try to look at the good
side and you pack their lunch even if
they say they don't like it and anyway
can go out of the example after example
right
teenagers are particularly bad
I love you screw you you know walking
out the door well Dan is not mutual
affection and until the child becomes
mature the child cannot really be in a
full sense the friend of the parent and
it's not the parents position while
they're exercising that parental kind of
love or care to try to be friends with
the kid usually when parents say things
like yeah my kids best friend
that's usually a should be a red flag
and this probably is not you know a kid
who's who's well-adjusted because part
of what it means to be a parent is to
actually lay down limits which to the
kid are going to seem irrational unfair
taking away my freedom you hate me I
hate you all that sort of stuff only
later with a better perspective can a
transform into something like this with
maturity right so Socrates is bringing
of that now this would seem to involve
something quite different than that a
lot of the other types of love or
friendship that he's talking about it
would be nice if you would have explored
this more but he didn't so this is one
of those places where you have to kind
of figure it out and call it out further
yourself instead Socrates now starts
getting into all these discussions about
who can be friends with who and then why
why are we friends with people he starts
looking at similarity we have the lover
well rather be logged but it's in terms
of some sort of thing in common we often
think about friendship something right
there they're based on having things in
common yeah I did you know we talked
just a little bit earlier about you had
to get some friends who you're friends
with because you're basically breathing
the same air in the same place at the
same time you're not going to stay
friends with them because that's that's
not much in common the stranger that you
meet on the train the person that you
play with on the playground kids are
terrible for saying I made a new friend
like what's your friend's name I don't
know where did you meet them right over
there on the playground five minutes ago
they're not a friend yet you know there
needs to be something more than just
being engaged in the same activity
before we should call it friendship but
friends do have some things in common
all right what if friends like to do and
they hang out your experience what do
you like to be with your friends
probably a lot of the stuff we've talked
about so far listen to music
we must be watching a video what else
what do you like to do food and drinks
yeah food and drinks are very important
there they're part of the glue that
holds things together so again you know
how to cook you are setting yourself up
go ahead Fred wise most likely you need
a good personality to cooking they'll go
a long ways
yeah watching movies together in movies
are sort of our culture's artistic
products so we don't often read books
together there are book flops and things
like that but that's more rare isn't it
a lot of times by the way book clubs are
you know excuse to get together and
drink kill time but even the drinking
and hanging out at the same place that's
you know something in common the fact
that they're lying to you know whoever
that they're going to a book club where
they're not actually reading books
that's something in common
not something particularly good in
common but and you know we can go
further and further further
what are the things we can have in
common with our friends you have
activities in common interests well yeah
yeah that would be an activity you know
when you meet the same group of people
for pickup games every Saturday that's
you develop friendships that way yeah
a lot of people learn how to golf
because golfing is supposed to help you
with developing you know contacts
okay that's an interesting to be an
interesting day aggression will come
back to the things of why do you think
that support okay there's there might be
some things we really shouldn't disagree
or it won't work like if I think that
I'm killing people for sport is a okay
and you don't we're not gonna be friends
that's that's a big problem well yeah
you know I I like Mexican food and
you're not really into that but I make
you some stuff and you're like wow this
isn't like tex-mex that I've had a
central thanks again oh yes I like this
stuff after all you've been exposed to
new things
yeah my wife often you know makes fun of
the fact that I've you know over time
figured out what my musical tastes
mainly are and they mainly lie in
certain modern classical stuff which I
listen to sometimes and 1970s and 80s
heavy metal which I listened to almost
all the time that I listen to things she
has this very very wide range of stuff
that she listens to and so of course you
know I'm kind of sticking through that
and we're listening to a band yesterday
and I do like other things yeah so we're
listening to this band gomez that I'd
heard one me song of before and it boy
it was really great stuff and I was like
wow right glad you had me listen to this
because I just assumed that their music
wasn't any good because it's now stuff
anything to listen to so yeah that is
that there's an argument to be made
there let's come back to it's a
similarity
what's deeper than common interests or
being in the same place
activities what's more you than where
you are what you're interested in what
you do yeah yeah the field of what we
call ethics our values our priorities
our character if I'm a fundamentally bad
guy you probably can't be friends with
me for very long the sooner or later I'm
going to screw you over that's part of
what it means to be a bad guy you know
friends can have and kind of things like
yeah we get together and then we
vandalize stuff you know we you know we
get together and we rob old ladies
they're probably not going to be friends
any sort of deep-level they're probably
using the word friends very loosely in
that case and the kind of people that
are going to do that sort of thing are
probably not going to actually be that
close to each other they may think that
they are because maybe that's all that
they can see but Socrates point is bad
people aren't even really friends with
themselves they don't even really have
them this is the same thing in common
with themselves for long and they
usually can't stand being by themselves
that's why they seek each other off so
you're probably not going to be able to
have this kind of friendship with
somebody who's bad and he's done some
weird things about good people morally
good people this is the point of the
tacks where you should be no red flag
should go up when you read it through so
if you're a good person then you're
giving your friends something else in a
turn right and you're getting something
from them now if your friend is really
similar to you not just in what they're
interested in but in the core of who
they are that means that you're similar
to them as well alright so if if I
really liked this person because they
can they can help me out there's a kind
of person who will show up and help me
move or something like that they're
they're giving me some sort of good
that's useful to me but if I'm really
the same as them I should be able to
supply that myself shouldn't I because
anything that they can get me I can
already get myself if what I needed from
them is you know smiling at me and
saying hey good job you know the work
that you do is really really helpful
can't I just talk myself down Socrates
seems to say that you can what do you
guys think about that yeah
yeah that that's the term he doesn't use
but yeah in a way it has a deep risk of
narcissism I'm just gonna I don't need
any other people I'll just tell myself
what a small guy I am
yeah there's there's something missing
it's not exactly the same if you tell me
that I'm doing a good job it doesn't
feel the same for me as my just looking
in the mirror and saying you're doing
such a great job keep up the good work
there's something that we do get from
the other person so keep that somebody
else that had their hand up over over
here I don't know
stifle any okay so keep that in the back
your mind he also brings up another
thing yeah this guy Hesiod he's a poet
and the Greeks looked at poets in a very
different way think of poets as being
sort of like their religious literature
things that they whip out no only people
you know quote the Bible spare the rod
spoil the child well you know Hesse had
said powder quarrels with powder barn
with barred beggar with beggar what do
you mean by that well similarities often
I guess this probably gets to some of
what you're talking about it wasn't that
big of a digression actually
similarities sometimes drive us nuts
don't think somebody's too similar to us
they become a not a friend but a rival
or a frenemy you guys know all that term
somebody's movie you think as a friend
but you're really like trying to
undermine each other all the time
maybe that is the case for solving some
similarities but but is that the case
for all of them probably not now
Socrates does two other things that are
important to keep in mind in this he
also lays out this is very complicated
arguments we're not gonna have the time
to
it's on the handout about you know why
only the not good but not bad person can
be friends with a good person on account
of the bad meaning that the good people
don't need anything from each other so
they're not really friends bad people
can't be friends anyway
we can't be friends with those who are
too similar to us so we can come back
again to the friendship as Mead you know
and as satisfaction of needs thing if
I'm friends with somebody who's good
it's on account of the good that they
provide me but that's because I'm
worried about the bad thing that I want
to avoid or prevent or get rid of that
the good thing can help me with so it's
good to be friends with doctors why
because when you get sick which is
something bad the badness won't
completely infect you they can cure you
and this is kind of a weird thing to say
as Socrates part you know it's it's it's
really pushing stuff and his
interlocutors there you know they go
along with it why is leave as they don't
know any better
not yet but you don't necessarily have
to do that this makes it sound like all
there really is is usefulness once again
we're back in that position
is that the way that you want to think
of things when it comes to to friends
probably not you want a world in which
the only reason we're friends with each
others because we're useful to each
other so what could be another
possibility
Socrates suggests this and he calls it
the the congenial this is a great word
I'm not gonna the Greek word up they're
just going to put another word fitting
something that matches up with things
within us I mean he's got this long
complicated argument of if you took evil
away when all the desires remain you
know the point of that is there are some
things that we actually do desire
whether we're waiting something bad for
us or not and why do we desire these
things well the ideas that we have we
have some sort of human nature and then
we have our own personality and there
are certain things that are appropriate
that are befitting to that you respond
to and you're like yeah like that that
match up with you something completes
you in a way that's what the the
congenial or the befitting is that's
what he means by it when you meet
somebody who you become infatuated with
you may become infatuated on this
account because something in your
response to who they are
maybe you're just imagining it of course
that's a possibility but maybe it's
really there and you you find a part of
yourself you you didn't even know it's
there
same thing when you have a deep
friendship that develops you you find
that the person fits you and now it's
not just about need anymore
it's not just about satisfaction of you
know getting something that you don't
like out of the way or giving you
something that you you want and have
been desiring it's more about who they
are more about who you are
he doesn't spell this out any further he
doesn't go any any further with this
because he says well isn't that just
similarity you know he he could have
gone a different way
at this point in the dialogue and his
thing the other guys in the dialogue
didn't think well enough to go the other
way
you can go the other way and some of the
other texts that we're going to read are
going to go the other way so these are a
bunch of different ways of thinking
about love and friendship now that you
can mull over see what you think of them
see where they map onto your life
experience and also think about this
think about what it is that you want for
the rest of your life which kind of
friendships do you want to avoid or love
relationships which kind of you want to
to him and think out that workout